how's the gun rest my name bad
welcome to paranormal it's a it's a
indie horror game and it's pretty cool
hello my name is Mattel Clark call nine
grad work at home as an artist uh-huh
and your game my house is haunted okay
lately things have been going bump at
night uh-huh Oh what so I'm at the cabin
I'm not crazy you're crazy man and you
know it but it's okay I really start
breaking cut a bit I guess that's what
you gave gay gay not a gay talking easy
bro you're crazy bro it's just how it is
bro anyway since this is in beta you
have to deal with this stuff
it's 1930 no it's not it's not Craig the
match is about to get call of duty where
is everyone I will kill you
how does this [ __ ] isn't that call of
duty oh well
exactly better ooh like that a lens
flare and the head I'm not touching but
it still likes whoa whoa boxes are
moving boxes what did I tell you about
moving I put a cat inside so that's why
sup catty you're not this is Jeremy stop
Jeremy
he's my buddy hey I like to play with
him I like the hump in Jeremy Jeremy is
pretty much my [ __ ] that's that's this
the story of that we got the boxes we
cats in them Jeremy and this one is my
masterpiece I call it that guy who tries
to stand inside a ball but he it's not
really standing it's really nice artwork
I do around here you know what do you
think about that Jeremy whoa come from
really freaking - cut coming from the
kitchen
am i a [ __ ] they're like I'm really
short what some someone [ __ ] with me
your turn underwater alright kind of
creepy I guess is an iPhone can I pick
it up no course not
let's see what's in the fridge oh look
at that
hey there a yes yet oh no hi bandit
fridge did you brucey no fridge ice upon
Oh Jeremy what are you doing over there
not cool man alright sounds in the fun
huh mom tell you not cool mom kind of
busy being spoon Jeremy I told you what
did I tell about the state didn't
sacrifices man yeah
god damn Jeremy needs satanic ways
pissed now Jeremy oh that's right you
stand inside the wall you I try to be a
lifter whoa I'm [ __ ] late back so pit
disappointed you can never leave for me
a pity you should set aside Jeremy I'm
going out to take a piss
which you will pee in the bathroom baby
shut up Jared and Jeremy oh you're
testing me now Jeremy its curse whoa
what what
someone punching my head hey I'm no I
short but that doesn't mean god damn it
hey this [ __ ] hey my cats go cats
are you okay why is it coming from oh oh
doo doo doo doo I didn't even know what
the [ __ ] happened no cool hey running
out of battery here let's go sir
alright so apparently what happened up
here whoa whoa no no no no no Michael
Jackson are you working with the bow
[Applause]
mister [ __ ] ain't even get to explore
everything I guess it's over well thank
God for that damn girl
I didn't get any trophies oh hell no
uh-uh
all right that was paranormal it's free
so if you want check it out I'll leave
your download link in description
it's random too so I think I'll check it
out again or should I do
yeah I think that'll be it I don't want
to really play it anymore but anyway I
really enjoyed this guy to come Bridget
and I'll see you next video whatever I
try to make somebody go Tarzan I won I
nail it